bonjour clos soit futurs parents jeunes
parents ou même grands parents la petite
enfance est un sujet qui nous tient tous
à coeur la petite enfance sont des
enfants de moins de 3 ans en pleine
l'acquisition de la marche du langage de
la vie en groupe enfants fragiles par
définition des enfants adorables aussi
pendant encore quelques années et par
dessous tout ce sont ce que nous avons
de plus cher au monde
alors est ce que ces enfants en crèche
en collectivité si on les observe
attentivement n'ont ils pas quelque
chose à nous apprendre
malgré leur grande inexpérience de la
vie à nous apprendre à nous les adultes
sur un fonctionnement en collectivité
sur une socialisation réussi sur un
vivre ensemble sans a priori
alors puisque à l'origine de tout il y à
l'enfant regardons de plus près son
incroyable potentiel étude après étude
recherches après recherche
on voit bien les bénéfices évidents de
bon sens d'un accueil de qualité sur le
jeune enfant pour son développement
physique émotionnel et mental bien
évidemment on le voit ici avec une étude
de l'institut du développement du jeune
enfant à harvard qui nous montre que dès
les premiers mois de la vie
beaucoup de choses se jouent les
fonctions essentielles comme la vue et
l'ouïe
dès les premiers mois le langage dès la
première année et les fonctions
cognitives supérieures telles que
l'empathie par exemple dès la deuxième
année
alors tout n'est pas joué avant trois
ans mais s'en prend sacrément la
direction est-ce que les pédopsychiatres
du xxème siècle avait imaginé de manière
intuitive aujourd'hui les neurosciences
l'imagerie cérébrale
eh bien nous le prouver nous le confirme
et on commence juste à cerner
l'incroyable potentiel en termes de
développement et d'acquisition et
d'apprentissage du jeune enfant
s'il est mis dans de bonnes conditions
alors comme l'enfant construit son monde
extérieur le vivre ensemble avant son
monde intérieur
comment pouvons-nous aujourd'hui
capitaliser sur cette période de la vie
qui est si particulière et où les
enfants cette capacité à apprendre de
manière exponentielle
regardons de plus près cette image du
cortex toujours provenant d'harvard
d'être cet institut pour le
développement du jeune enfant
on y voit dans la partie supérieure le
cerveau d'un enfant qui est mis dans de
bonnes dispositions pour apprendre un
milieu favorisé on voit que le cortex
est vivant il est riche il est dense les
réseaux les le réseau neuronal est au
rendez vous alors que dans l'image du
dessous un enfant défavorisé isolés dont
l'acte et les gens c'est l'activité
n'est pas stimulé et bien on a un réseau
neuronal qui pour le coup n'est pas là
où il devrait être
et c'est d'autant plus important que
dans le cas d'un enfant venant d'un
milieu défavorisé
si la famille monoparentale par exemple
s'il est fragilisé dans son
environnement et c est bien ce que vous
voyez là c'est ensuite un retard énorme
pour la suite de sa vie on va prendre
l'exemple du langage par exemple un
enfant généralement arrivent à l'école
avec mille mots de vocabulaire s'il
arrive d'un milieu défavorisé ses 500 mo
un adulte c'est un peu près 8000 mots et
ses sens aux mots de retard vont le
poursuivre toute sa scolarité savall
pénalisé sur l'apprentissage de la
lecture de l'écriture notamment
et pourtant il suffirait de deux mots
par jour entre l'acquisition du langage
et l'entrée en maternelle avec deux mots
par jour
les enfants arrivent avec 1500 mots à
l'école non pas 500 n'ont pas 1000 mhz
et 1500 alors vous imaginez tous
d'aplomb mais une deuxième locomotive au
lieu de pousser le dernier wagon alors
on le voit bien le développement est
essentiel sur l'enfant mais
repositionnons ce développement dans le
cadre de la crèche
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une crèche
finalement contrairement au classement
pisa
on voit bien que la france se traîne à
la 25e place pour le coup en ce qui
concerne la petite enfance on est plutôt
les bons élèves de la planète et c'est
grâce à un écosystème unique qui a été
mis en place en france et qui met autour
de la table dans le cadre d'un vrai
partenariat public privé
les caisses d'allocations familiales les
gestionnaires et les médecins de la
protection maternelle et infantile et
finalement ça donne un mode de garde qui
est privilégiée par les familles
puisqu'il est riche pédagogiquement
puisqu'il permet un juste équilibre
entre les activités de jeux libres et de
temps calme avec les activités plus liés
au développement psychomoteur et de
groupe avec les activités dans le jardin
les activités dans la section avec une
ergonomie architectural qui se prêtent à
l'accueil d'un enfant de cet âge là et
tout ça c'est essentiel pour le
développement de la confiance en soi et
de l'estimé de soi du jeune enfant et
puis surtout ça se fait pas tout seul
c'est animé par des professionnels de la
petite enfance qui sont diplômés qui
sont des curricula trice des éducatrices
de jeunes enfants des auxiliaires de
puériculture
ur et qui ensemble font vivre un vrai
projet pédagogique une cohérence
éducative et cette cohérence éducatif
elle se retrouve essentiellement dans la
notion de coéducation coéducation
c'est-à-dire accompagner les familles
dans l'éducation de leurs enfants ne pas
se substituer à l'air donc finalement
contribué pas à pas à l'éveil d'une
génération
et ça c'est possible parce que ces
professeurs de petite enfance choisi ce
métier par passion par engagement et
c'est d'autant plus important que la
crèche a aussi une vocation de cohésion
sociale c'est un îlot qui permet de
concilier la vie professionnelle la vie
sociale et la vie familiale qui parfois
est freinée erratique et la crèche grâce
à l'universalité de son accueil permet
d'accueillir tout le monde quel que soit
son milieu quel que soit son statut
à la fois les couples b actifs les mères
célibataires ceux qui ont besoin d'un
accueil d'urgence ceux qui ont besoin
d'une aide pour le retour à l'emploi
ceux dont les enfants sont porteurs de
handicap tous les milieux et ça c'est
une réforme du système français
c'est cette notion de mixité sociale et
on le voit bien c'est une notion
d'inclusion
ce n'est pas de la ségrégation on pointe
du doigt un groupe à l'extérieur ce
n'est pas de l'intégration au pointe du
doigt un groupe à l'intérieur de la
crèche c'est de l'inclusion l'ensemble
des enfants sont ensemble parce qu'en
crèche on accueille l'enfant et sa
famille et non pas son éventuelle
différence
alors on le voit bien la crèche est un
lieu parfait en terme de sécurité
affective et physique de l'enfant
mais c'est surtout un lieu d'éveil les
fameux prémices de l'apprentissage
ce que la crèche ne l'oublions pas est
la première marche avant l'école
maternelle
et pour ça il faut des places de crèches
de qualité il faut que la pérennité
économique de nos crèches via nourrir et
servir l'innovation sociale et
l'excellence pédagogique vous voyez sur
ce graphe de james heckman kyi prix
nobel d'économie en 2001 et qui à
travers une étude longitudinale avec
l'université de chicago nous ont suivis
1500 enfants en crèche venant d'un
milieu défavorisé pendant 25 ans il en
arrive à la conclusion que un dollar
investi dans la petite enfance permet
d'économiser 10 dollars dans la société
plus tard que ce soit en soutien
scolaire en prévention de la délinquance
en lutte contre la pauvreté 1 $ pour 10
dollars et donc on voit bien l'immense
intérêt d'un investissement social et
éducatif le plus tôt possible le plus
précocement possible dans la petite
enfance
et pour cela il va falloir faire trois
choses il va vous falloir une sacrée
vision une vraie politique de la petite
enfance pour les années à venir qui va
reposer sur trois éléments
notre socle pédagogique les éducateurs
et les enfants bien évidemment
concernant le socle pédagogique
vous les connaissez vous les
reconnaissez
ce sont nos grands pédagogues nos grands
pédopsychiatre qui ont finalement animé
et bien ce qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui
dans les projets éducatifs et
pédagogiques entre esch
ce socle est nécessaire mais il est plus
suffisant il commence à être un peu
poussiéreux il commence à dater un peu
pour vous donner un exemple
winnicott avec sa théorie du doudou chez
le jeune enfant comme objet
transitionnel on pourrait parler aussi
de pickler avec tous ces travaux de
recherche sur l'activité chez le bébé on
pourrait parler dolto qui d'ailleurs
très belle phrase sur le vivre ensemble
sur le fait que vivre ensemble cette
notion de groupe tout groupe humain
prend sa richesse dans la communication
l'entraidé la solidarité
mais tous ces penseurs là et par exemple
c'est l'instinct freiner qui est à
l'origine de l'éducation nouvelle
célestin freinet c'était en 1930 c'était
il ya 90 ans est ce que finalement ce
socle pédagogique sur lequel
appuyez n'est pas certes nécessaire mais
plus du tout suffisant pour affronter le
monde de demain
ça c'est la première chose à deuxième
chose ce sont les éducateurs la moyenne
entre h aujourd'hui ses 31 ans et la
génération y mais je vais vous parler
d'histoire de l'oea les ait en
apprentissage pour exercer le métier
d'auxiliaire de puériculture
elle est née en février 2000
elle n'a pas connu le 20e siècle elle a
16 ans c'est une enfant du 21e siècle
c'est la fameuse génération z
elle veut d'une réelle veut donner du
sens à son engagement des jeunes filles
comme léa il y en aura une pour 5 en
2020 dans les crèches en france et en
2025 une pour 4 est-ce que nous sommes
prêts à les accueillir à les motiver à
faire en sorte qu'elles aient envie
d'embrasser cette carrière
qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir qu'on remette
en plein et en cause dans nos méthodes
pédagogiques pour les attirer cette
génération là elle veut des mousses elle
veut du e-learning elle veut pouvoir
échanger des meilleures pratiques à
travers la planète se demander comment
les italiens au niveau de la création
artistique ont su remettre en cause et
et ont su innover autour de la pédagogie
de reggio par exemple pour l'appliquer
en crèche
elles veulent comprendre ce que c'est
que la théorie du free flow dans les
pays nordiques qui permet aux enfants de
passer librement du jardin à l'intérieur
de la crèche quel que soit le climat et
la journée elles veulent comprendre
pourquoi les canadiens ont mis en place
des espaces non hélène qui permet aux
enfants finalement d'acquérir d'autres
venir zen tout simplement et d'avoir de
véritables espace sensoriel alors à leur
disposition pendant la journée dans la
crèche les générations z elle veut
comprendre ce qui se passe en termes de
multilingue en allemagne où les familles
dès l'âge d'un an jusqu'à 6 ans vont
choisir pour leurs enfants des sections
qui sont allemands anglais allemand
français et allemands chinois
donc oui il ya plein de choses il ya
plein de bonnes idées aller chercher à
travers la planète et cette génération
là elle elle le souhaite elle le demande
elle en veut sinon le métier ne sera pas
intéressant pour elle et puis bien
évidemment le voeu de l'information
continue parce que
fini le temps des cours magistraux en
amphi on obtient un diplôme et puis se
passe plus rien derrière
de la façon dont le monde bouge avec la
révolution digitale
il est juste essentiel demain que ces
éducateurs puisse avoir au moins une
semaine de formation complète par an
pour se mettre à niveau pour éveiller
leur curiosité et ainsi de suite
et puis une fois qu'on a parlé des
éducateurs il faut parler ensuite des
enfants bien évidemment préparé les
enfants au monde de demain
une étude du héritier et passionnante à
ce sujet les enfants qui sont en très
chaud aujourd'hui seront sur le marché
du travail en 2040 leur premier job ce
sera 2040 en 2040 priori tous les
métiers auront été disrupt et par les
nouvelles technologies et un métier sur
2 n'existe pas encore aujourd'hui alors
certes il faut continuer les savoirs
fondamentaux savoir compter savoir
écrire savoir lire mais est-ce que c'est
suffisant qu'est-ce qu'il faut donner
d'autres à cette jeunesse pour lui
permettre d'affronter le monde de demain
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
la boîte à outils le savoir être plutôt
que le savoir faire
l'intelligent signer situationnelle to
all the des pas deux mots par jour tout
autre jeu des passes que ce sera une
obligation d'être bilingue à cette
époque
voilà comment on va en faire des
citoyens exemplaires un maximum d'outils
faire de la diversité une force
n'oublions pas pousseront 9 milliards
d'individus sur terre en 2040 2
milliards de plus qu'aujourd'hui
et ça commence en crèche parce que en
crèche
notre mission c'est que les enfants
soient bien dans leur tête et bien dans
leur temps
et en conclusion si nous voulons
préparer le monde des adultes
inspirons-nous du monde des enfants si
nous voulons une société plus inclusive
prenons exemple sur l'harmonie qui
existent en crèche harmonie qui permet
aux enfants d'être heureux aux parents
d'être serein aux éducateurs d'être
motivé harmonique est une subtile un
subtil équilibre entre exigence et
bienveillance harmonique qui fait de la
crèche a lieu de joie et d'innovation
harmonie qui peut et qui doit nous
obliger à déployer cela après la crèche
sur l'école sur le monde de l'entreprise
sur la vie de tous les jours
harmonie qui met la famille au coeur est
avec la famille au coeur demain vivre
ensemble sera bien évidemment une
évidence mais surtout il fera bon
grandir tous ensemble merci
[Applaudissements]